how much debt do you technically have
255 million something like that pace
morby is the guy for all things real
estate he hosts the show triple digit
flip on a e he owns thousands of rental
properties and he does it all with
something called creative financing
which is a really fancy way of saying
he's able to build wealth without using
any of his own money total amount of
real estate that we own is somewhere
around 300 million today we get to have
him break down exactly
invest in real estate the best ways to
get started and how you are able to own
your own home even if you don't have a
ton of money so we really hope you enjoy
this one as always if you're not already
subscribed totally free takes you a
split second and as a thank you here's a
picture of a green eye blue red-eyed
tree frog how's that all right enjoy
welcome to the iced coffee hour big fan
I really appreciate it freaking dude
seriously you are the king of YouTube I
tell everybody all the time the king of
YouTube Graham stuff
that's a great title
here's the thing is people behind closed
doors like people that are trying to
build YouTube channels they all compare
their channel to what you're doing
four years ago five years ago still
today you have continually reinvented
yourself and done a great job you guys
are killing it thank you I really
appreciate it but today is all about you
and you've done some pretty incredible
things and you were also telling me
about something right before we shot
this podcast episode that blew my mind I
had no idea that this statistic actually
existed oh yeah I told you I cut you off
and I said wait wait we gotta save it
for the podcast Graham can react to it
yeah I can get an authentic reaction as
well oh it's not that big of a deal you
probably already know this uh there
there's currently 600 000 homes that are
non-performing in the United States and
so we're starting a business right now
we've got a Servicing Company that's
like take these houses off of our plate
just take them and so we're dividing
them out and conquering these houses I
mean literally 600 000 houses the
services will services will pay you
they'll pay you a thousand dollars to
just take over these houses can we get
this in layman's terms yes what do you
mean by non-performing so uh people that
are living in the homes that went out
and got it alone right there's a
Servicing Company that's receiving those
pain payments on behalf of the the
lender the homeowner stops making a
payment and it's very expensive for a
bank or a servicer to actually foreclose
on a home and so a lot of times they
just don't they look at the house and
they go it's not worth it for us and so
they go we we will actually pay somebody
to take this mortgage and take it take
over the mortgage
600 000 of them a year just sitting
there these more the mortgage servicing
companies will pay you
about twelve hundred dollars per house
to just take them off to their books so
if you want a thousand houses today
they'll pay you a million dollars to
take the houses now what's what's the
normal range for non-performing houses
600 000 of me in the US seems relatively
low my understanding is that there's a
few million per year prior to the
pandemic that just people fall Beyond on
payments they're more than like I think
it's more than 120 days late it's in the
millions you're talking millions and
millions we're talking we're talking
right now just the ones that people will
pay us to take I see yeah so it's a
subset of those correct that
what's the situation on that is it just
there's they're not so underwater on it
but it's like just you know right on the
line of like okay maybe we could break
even on this but it's interesting
because what we were what we're planning
on doing in that business is essentially
going to the servicer and saying pay us
twelve hundred dollars per house to take
them off your books what are we going to
do with them right I'm not just gonna
take over a thousand houses that's a lot
of Burden because now I've got people
living in these homes that now I'm the
bank right I'm the note holder that's a
problem I don't just own the house I'm
the lender on the house now so I have to
do something with these houses I have to
either a get them performing again so
calling the homeowners and saying hey
let's renegotiate let's make sure you're
taken care of which is what we is the
ideal situation or B we go hey let's
short sell these or C we go to them and
offer them cash to walk away like cash
for keys to walk away and then we put
them into the portfolio or D you could
wholesale them to fix and flippers or
I guess another way is you could
wholesale or you could fix and flip them
Fix and Flip them yourself if you choose
to do that which I'm not I don't love
fixing and flipping it's just a big
construction game that's all it is sure
and what's the status on these houses
where they bought recently like in this
past year or so and also like are they
in fine conditions oh that's kind of
that's a different statistic so houses
that were bought in 2021 2022 there's
about 450 000 of them that are already
underwater from people buying them in
2022 and now the market has gone down an
average of about 16 in the last year
that you know the US and so those people
that bought FHA or VA they're
significantly underwater right is that
like disproportionately high it's very
high yeah I mean think about units are
so low though interest rates are really
lower than if they bought the same house
today 20 less but nobody's buying in the
past few months and already is
underwater like with the super high
interest rates and also the high prices
yeah if they put three percent down
they're underwater yeah it's going to
cost them six percent just to sell so
like right off the bat then they're
losing three percent assuming the
Market's the same and then imagine the
market goes down five I think that's the
part that most people don't understand
about real estate is if I buy a house
today for 200 000 and then I turn around
and sell it for 200 000. most people
think oh you're gonna break even but
people that are in real estate we know
man you're going to lose probably close
to 10 because you've got real realtor
commissions plus closing costs sometimes
you'll have inspection stuff and you'll
have other weird concessions that you
have to pay as the seller the seller
pays all of that expense so what's
happening right now for us like I've got
an email just popped up here like 15
minutes ago this is actually one of my
big business models is that people come
to me and they go hey I've got a house
in San Antonio I'll let you just take
over the house and the mortgage at 3.6
percent so I haven't taken I haven't
bought a house over four percent in a
long long time even right now interest
rates are at seven and a half eight
percent right for homeowners what I do
and what people know me for is I just
take over other people's existing
mortgages subject too or I buy them on
seller finance so explain this deal they
got a 30-year fixed rate loan at 3.65
what do you do in that situation they're
behind on it yep so they bought they
bought it
um
let's see there
they're not behind Okay so they're not
behind on payments three bed two bath
house 1235 square feet it was built in
2021 so basically brand new okay first
lean position 192
000 their payment on that house is 11.55
so I immediately look at that and they
go we're trying to sell this but if we
sold it and paid realtor commissions and
all that stuff we're gonna walk away
having to write a check to get rid of
our house so somebody like me comes
along goes the asset is actually not
really the house the actu the asset is
actually the debt
a 3.65 percent that I don't have to
apply for that's the craziest thing
about real estate I don't even have to
apply for that loan I don't have to
assume it I don't have to apply for it
nobody checks my bank balance nobody
asks for my tax returns nobody asked for
anything no job history nothing I
literally go to a title company they
transfer the deed into my name I now own
the property the D the mortgage stays in
the seller's name now don't a lot of
these mortgages have a do on sale Clause
yeah 100 so what happens there so dual
cell Clause is something you should
definitely be worried about I own title
companies across the United States we do
see them from time to time it's about
one in 500 times that a sub 2
transaction this is a sub 2 transaction
where the seller walks away mortgage
stays in their name I take over the
existing mortgage what am I going to do
with that property I could do a variety
of things I could turn that into a
traditional rental I could do Section 8
depending on the neighborhood I could do
midterm rentals like traveling nurses
corporate rentals sober living is really
really good if you want to do sober
living I love sober living not because I
operate sober living but because I find
operators who do sober living and they
pay double the rent rate to operate
sober living
sober living is like somebody goes into
a drug addiction Center and the
government essentially
gets them through pays for that service
and then when they leave they need a
place to stay the government pays that
650 to 750 per bed so mostly sober
living facilities have seven to ten beds
in a house and the government's paying
750 per bed they don't have to be
licensed to do this it's a big business
in Beverly Hills when I was in agent
huge you would almost have to you would
almost have to ask when someone you
would have these houses with like seven
to ten bedrooms in them and it got to a
point where I got so many calls and I
would automatically say this is for
sober living because there were so many
of them and they would offer more than
what we were charging in rent
yeah double interesting yeah most of the
time double yeah so you can look at a
house like this that is my payment that
I'm taking over right because I'm taking
over somebody's payment is 1155 bucks a
regular rent rate on this is 1500 yeah
about 15 1600 bucks so on a reg the Cody
Sanchez friend of mine she always
trashes Real Estate Investors because
she's like oh I don't want to go buy
houses because I'm only making 400 a
month in cash flow I'm like yeah if
you're doing traditional rental but if
you do midterm or short term which is
Airbnb or you do sober living you're
double cash flow plus I have a fixed
debt for 30 years right and what happens
to rents every three years I get to bump
my rent's 150 bucks my debt doesn't
change but my rent I can just keep
bumping my rent every three years now
what happens though if the due on sale
Clause oh this comes up this is great it
does happen Okay first time um there's a
couple of things about this and this is
something that real estate agents don't
know but it isn't in the real estate
exam it's like that 20 that they fail on
it's the it's called an executory
contract okay so have you ever sold a
car cash
I have okay and you have a title right
and you sign the title you notarize it
and you hand it to your buyer yeah when
does the buyer become the owner of that
car I believe is as soon as they sign
right so they don't sign you are the
only one that signs okay right so you
sign over the title the second they have
possession of the title sure is when
they become the owner okay why because
they now control the asset sure does
that make sense so they can go down to
the DMV or MVD whatever they call it and
you can record that document today or
you record it in a week you can record
it in 30 days but you're the owner
because you control that document does
that make sense yeah okay so what
triggers the do on Cell Clause I'm going
to come back to that what triggers the
do and sell Clause probably when you
report it right there you go okay when
the deed is transferred right so this is
interesting Jack you're not a real
estate guy right I have a house but
that's about it love it okay cool so you
have a house you have a mortgage right
so you pay a payment yeah and you're the
owner yes cool so think about this if I
go to a grocery store and I use a credit
card you're a big credit card guy you
like credit cards right I go buy
groceries with a Visa credit card those
groceries come to me
but I use somebody else's money to buy
them who's the owner of those groceries
me how do you know you use somebody
else's money because I have possession
of them okay possession but you also
have something else what else do you
have
the receipt oh okay okay the receipt
proves that you have ownership right so
in real estate what is the receipt it's
the deed Whoever has the deed or control
of the deed is the owner of real estate
so your mortgage company is not the
owner of your house right no they're not
they're not just like the credit card
company is not the owner of those
groceries so there's the debt and then
there's the ownership documents they're
not the same they're exclusively
separate so you're saying you just hold
the deed you can okay so let me get to
this okay I'm building up to it sure so
if I take over a deed on a sub 2
transaction right here on the San
Antonio deal okay if I take over the
deed and let's say in six months the
mortgage company notices this is when he
says do on sale Clause this is what that
means mortgage company goes hey Pace
took over that house subject to without
paying off the debt they transferred the
ownership from owner a to Pace
without paying us off they have the
ability not the obligation they have the
ability to demand that I pay them off
because I I bought the house that's just
info with the entire yes in full yeah
usually it's like 60 days or something
like that yeah so they have to go
through the foreclosure process to make
it happen Okay so that's called the do
on sale Clause so that poses a risk to
two people poses a risk to the person
who sold the house to you and then it
also poses a risk to you who just bought
the house where you're like I didn't put
any money down I took over the mortgage
payments I've now got tenants in this
property I'm cash flowing those tenants
are paying down this mortgage that I
just took over this thing is awesome all
of a sudden I get a letter in the mail
that says we demand you pay us that's
the due on sale class what do you do in
that situation
you can do a couple things one you could
sell the house but what happens if you
don't have Equity well you could
refinance it but that doesn't really
that's not fun because now you got to
bring money to the table or you can go
back to the bank and you can renegotiate
with them which is usually what we'll do
and say hey just so you know we did buy
it subject two but we're performing and
we're making the payments ninety percent
of the time they're fine with it the
first time I ever had to do on sale
Clause happened to me and you're gonna
enjoy this as a as a very intelligent
real estate guy
it's a house on Lost Dutchman Trail
house was in foreclosure I catch up the
arrears right it was twenty one thousand
dollars you know what that means catch
up the ears uh was that just the Lost
payments there you go so they're they're
behind on five months of payments I came
out in and I caught up the payments the
very next day I took the deed to the
house but I kept the mortgage in place I
bought it subject too so I get a letter
about a month later and it's a bank
called Johnson Bank really small Branch
like teeny little Branch four branches
and the letter says we demand that you
pay us we're calling the due on sale
clause or the acceleration Clauses
sometimes they call it and so we called
the bank I luckily get a hold of
magically it's such a small bank I get a
hold of the actual owner of the bank
I go hey my name's Pace we caught up the
the arrears I bought the house sub too
what's the problem he goes oh no no we
saw that you caught up the arrives
that's great I appreciate that a lot of
our clients buy Sub 2. it's not a
problem but there's a better way to do
this with a bank like us I go okay
what's the way to do this so he says I
suggest you do it one of two ways either
a
deed the property back to the homeowner
so that it doesn't it untriggers the due
on sale clause
and in that case now have him deed the
property back to you but don't record
the transaction so essentially holding
the title and what we do in those
situations that the do on sale Clause
happens I deed it back to the homeowner
homeowner resigns the deed back to me
but I hold it in a safety deposit box
but now
City going to get involved because now
it's let's just say the property is
going to be reassessed at a different
price now now the city is not
reassessing a property the latest sale
price correct
yeah they get reassessed yeah but would
they not though because you're not
recording a deed no in in a sub 2
transaction no they're not re they're
not reassessing no and is it not a
problem with the city
or a state I feel like a state like
California would be cracking down and
and because they want their money and
they want the the city and local
revenues on that I've not we've never
ran into it and the average time we hold
the property is seven to ten years
anyway right we'll refinance or we'll
pull Equity out of the deal or we'll
sell their house or whatever else never
ran into that at all never once and what
if you miss a payment isn't there if we
missed to the 100 100 just like if you
if Jack misses a payment on his mortgage
there's risk to his mortgage company
right there's definitely risk to the
homeowner for sure but they're putting a
lot of trust in you not to make that
right so it depends right so there's two
different well let's go back to the
Johnson Bank thing real quick and I'll
put a cap on that and we'll go to that
because this is a really good question
so that's one way you can do it or you
so you can buy it on an executory
contract that's what that's called right
so when you sign your title over on a
car that you own and you sign that off
in that situation that's called an
Executor contract means he has not
executed the final part of the
transaction and he holds that in limbo
until your let's say you sell a car to a
homeowner or to the next car owner he
changes the car tires he paints it he
could essentially take the title never
record it and then hand it to the next
buyer and up charge it does that make
sense that's an Executor contract so you
can do it in an executive an executory
contract where it doesn't get recorded
or B
you can do it as a lease option or the
option price is the mortgage balance the
day you execute the option does that
make sense sure okay so that that
overcomes the doing so but then that
also implies that the seller is actually
paying down the mortgage correct right
so you put in the lease option that the
payments that you the buyer or the lease
option tenant is paying actually paid
down the mortgage and the buyer gets
credit for those payments and what about
in the event of a lawsuit let's just say
someone Sues and they they try to go
after the property but the property's
not in your name the properties in the
seller's name or vice versa they get in
a lawsuit and someone sees well there's
a deed to this house that they
technically own right what would happen
so what you do is your agreement for
sale in Arizona or contract for deed or
land contract or whatever it's called in
other states technically an Executor
contract it the agreement gets attached
to the property and protects you from a
lawsuit the deed does not get
transferred if that makes sense so
somebody come after the property trying
to to sue the owner will pull up and go
oh wow the owner actually doesn't
control this asset anymore it's this
person who controls it anyone who gets
sued technically say well no I transfer
the eat over here and he just never
recorded it isn't that a way to get out
of any lawsuit if someone tries to sue
you I see people do it all the time I
had somebody that when I was a
contractor 10 years ago I had somebody
owed me money and I go I went to go sue
them and they transferred the deed to
one of their other llc's on a property I
tried to sue them on happens all the
time I feel like there's got to be a
clause in there because otherwise
everyone everyone would be doing this
just like every asset it's happening
it's happening thousands of times in
every state it's happening now recording
them yeah it happens all the time if you
look in any state it's called an
executory contract it's legal it's been
around for hundreds of years it's
happening all the time I bet you in
Vegas it's happening a thousand times a
month or more our title companies we
probably see 10 of the time in Arizona
10 of the transactions we see are called
agreement for sale transactions which
means the deed does not get transferred
a Servicing Company holds the deed in
limbo until the F the buyer ends up
doing something with that that property
does that make sense so what's the risk
because I'm still skeptical man there's
a lot of risks but yeah there's a lot of
risk
question I've been like thinking in my
head for a while if somebody is holding
a note and they're making a mortgage
payment paying for the utilities and
everything like that for example in that
the numbers that you provided right
there yeah as soon as they become a
renter their monthly expense on the
house is just going to be immediately
increased and what you're doing is
basically paying them back the five to
twenty percent or whatever how much
Equity they have in the house you're
saying in this situation so this person
that I'm taking over their mortgage yeah
they're not staying in the house oh
that's Cardinals that's like cardinal
sin of creative Finance you don't you
never let the homeowner stay in the
house do you that you buy the house from
them so there's two ways to do this
they're subject two right that's me
taking over the existing mortgage and
then there's seller finance okay what's
the difference between the two
difference is seller finances there's no
debt right the seller then finances me
right and the way I explain that to
people is
um the way I
um explain seller finances I sold an
F-150 actually I sold another F-150 last
week Kelly Blue Book value is 20 grand I
sold it for 47 000 on seller finance how
did I do that I went to somebody who
doesn't have credit and I said hey make
me 500 payments at 40 40 000 plus
interest and I can sell or Finance you
right we just created a promissory note
and that's the agreement between two
parties seller finance pretty simple
um subject two means there's an existing
debt right I'm taking over car payments
would be subject to right if you go on
my YouTube channel you'll see I buy
people's cars subject to in subject two
people have pain in seller finance the
sellers are have there have a desire for
gain okay
subject to handles a need seller finance
satisfies greed okay so when you say
well there's risk for the homeowner well
typically I'd say 80 percent of the
transactions that we do with subject to
the homeowner is in foreclosure they're
in some really bad situation they're
going to lose the house anyway and we
come along go guys do not let this house
go to foreclosure that debt is a really
good debt I'll pay you five grand or two
grand or a thousand bucks or I'll pay
your moving expenses to move to an
apartment do not let that house go to
foreclosure let me catch up your arrears
let me get the mortgage back in good
standing and rebuild your credit and
I'll take over that house and the
responsibility of it now that's not
going to be like somebody that doesn't
want to be a real estate investor but
I'm a real estate investor that's what I
want because otherwise how am I buying
rental properties I'm going to a
mortgage company and I'm having them
pull my credit they're going to limit me
to 10 maybe 12 mortgages at a time and
I'm going to put down 20 30 especially
in this economy I'm going to get a
mortgage at seven percent eight percent
I haven't gotten a mortgage over
3.8 percent in probably seven eight
years this seems like something the
mortgage industry though would love to
crack down on because maybe wouldn't
they want to get these loans off of
their books at three percent so well the
mortgage company this is this is
happening all behind the scenes anyway
or if you go back and you watch The Big
Short these guys are swapping mortgages
all the time mortgage companies don't
hold notes what mortgage companies do is
they originate alone and then they sell
the loan but the original investor now
wants to have that three percent loan
paid off charged off they want to get
that off their books to make way for
something at six percent or five percent
yeah I think the value of their loans go
down because they have all these three
percent loans out there when you could
get six percent right now yeah 100 but I
don't think they have the technology or
the the no the know-how to go back and
go all right we're gonna go to these
ones and know whether these are
homeowners or Real Estate Investors and
nor can they come in call a note on a
30-year fixed deal if you haven't
violated or just done wrong right
subject two has been around for hundreds
of years but don't they still reserve
the right yeah to do the to call the
loan yes even even if you call them I've
had the I've had to do I've had the due
on sale Clause calling me five times
where we were not able to negotiate with
the bank and every single time we just
deeded the property back and repurchase
on a lease option okay that's it do on
sale closet and I've never known one
person one person ever that has lost a
property due on sale never once it's the
boogeyman it's like the number one thing
that real estate agents and Brokers
bring up to me because it's something
they were taught in real estate school
or maybe like continued education
credits and I'm like guys that's a
boogeyman find one person that's ever
lost a house to do on sale
because they all bring it up to me but
none of them have the one single example
ever yeah and I've even when I'm the
creative Finance guy everybody in the
country calls me I've never met one
person that's lost a house to do on sale
clause never once and I've had it called
on me but I know how to overcome it sure
and it is it is a risk for sure yeah how
did you get started in all this what's
uh what's your background
um I was a contractor
for a long time and um I worked for Open
Door offer pad Zillow I was their
contractor and I would go around and I
would set up all their locations so I
set up Dallas for them in Vegas for them
and I would take the red eye and Just
Bounce Around setting up construction
sites and I was
um you know I owned my own construction
company and I did about 7 000
Renovations for these guys so I knew the
industry up and down and I had this
homeowner that would not a homeowner she
was a flipper her name is Bethany and
Bethany calls me up she goes hey you
have a great reputation I see you
flipping all these houses for the these
other investors come flip a house for me
and I go flip a house for I'm a
contractor I got my cruise so we go
crush it for done do a second house done
she calls me for a third house I show up
early
and she comes up behind me pulls it
behind me knocks on my glass and she
goes get out of your truck right now she
like makes me come and sit on the back
bed of my truck and I'm like what did I
do and she was like
why aren't you in real estate
like what do you mean she's like every
contractor I know shows up late they
overbid me they overcharge they make
excuses you are the opposite opposite of
that why are you a contractor
I go I I don't know she goes why aren't
you in real estate and I go I am in real
estate
and I was lying to myself I thought I
was in real estate she says something
that that really shocked me she said
you're not in real estate you're a
service provider to me and I'm in real
estate you are a simple Google search
away from being replaced and I was like
dang she says you're as replaceable as a
mobile notary
I can Google and get a different mobile
notary yours replaceable as a real
estate agent if I don't like my agent
I'll switch them out here's replaceable
as the mortgage company you're as
replaceable as my private money lender
I'm gonna ask you again why are you not
in real estate you figured out the
hardest part of real estate which is the
construction right like when you built
your house I'm sure you had delays and
you went up there was budget things and
change orders and all that kind of stuff
that's actually the hardest part of real
estate is the construction and
Renovations and the permits and all the
prop like that's the hard part and I go
I guess I don't know where the deals
come from
I have no idea where the deals come from
I just assumed that you guys know
something I don't know and I also don't
know where the money comes from and so
she broke it down and she said she says
I want you to send out a swath of
postcards you know my postcards like I
don't know anything about sending out
postcards and she stops and she calls me
an she's like stop being an
and ask like you keep asking all
these questions take some freaking
action pull out your phone and call this
postcard company I'm like but what do I
tell them she goes you don't have to
tell them anything they know what the
heck to do they know where to send the
postcards what they should look like
what ZIP codes blah blah blah blah
so I she makes me call right there I
send out 10 000 postcards and I get my
first deal two weeks later I got a deal
from a lady named Janie Munson I made 25
Grand on it and I was like this took me
three hours of work to do this why am I
a freaking contractor it took me you
know I'm working as a contractor making
good money I made I made my first
million dollars in a year
back in 2014 2013 from open door open
door paid me they never squabble that
prices they paid me on time I was their
shining Golden Boy and I took home a
million bucks back in 2013 2014 and took
home after taxes
um and then Bethany also pointed out to
me she says if you were actually in real
estate and you made all that money you
would have taken home 1.6
I'm like really I knew nothing about
cost segregation I knew nothing about uh
you know depreciation knew nothing about
any of that stuff so here I am paying
all these taxes
and so she sat me down and she really
taught me how to get into the business I
got my first deal and that first deal
was a cash deal let me tell you how I
got the deal okay so I knew nothing I
didn't know how to fill out a contract I
didn't know how to comp a house I didn't
know how to do any of that stuff but
Bethany says send out the postcards so I
send out the postcards third phone call
I get is a lady named Janie Genie
retiring school teacher has lived in the
house for over 40 years thinks she's
renovated that house as a school teacher
no house is in horrible condition
40 years not renovated the hot water
heater was like 25 years old like the
fact that it made it that long is
surprising
so she calls me up and I go should I go
hi this is Paige she goes um you buy
houses right and I go yeah but I had no
idea what I was doing right and she goes
so what's our next step I got
I don't know so I literally got on the
other line I go can I ask my partner so
I call Bethany on the other line the
lady who told me to send out postcards I
go I gotta lead but I don't know what to
do she's like you go on a freaking
appointment you idiot go to the house
take photos go meet the person like what
do you think you're gonna do
okay that's how little I knew about the
real estate game right and so I get on
the other line I set the appointment I
go meet with her and I walk into our
kitchen we start building Rapport I look
on her kitchen table and there's real
estate agent cards there's postcards
there's letters she's got a whole
massive amount of people that have been
marketing to her and so I asked her the
question I was like really genuinely had
no idea I'm like why have you not sold
your house like you've got all these
people what do you need me for she goes
well I've met with 15 people already
have you ever met like when you were
doing listing appointments did you meet
with anybody that would take the time to
go to 15 like take 15 agents
time usually no no it's like two maybe
three right so she went through 15
before she called me so she called I go
okay well what what's kept you from
selling the house and she says I have an
offer
but it's not high enough
and I go what's the offer now here's the
thing before I tell you what her offer
was on my drive up to the house I called
Bethany and go what should I pay for the
house I give her the address she comps
it she says as a fix and flipper Bethany
was a fix and flipper I would pay 150
for the house side unseen so don't offer
her anything over 150 I'll partner with
you on the deal I'll be your partner and
we'll go flip it together
I go okay so when uh Genie says well I
already have an offer but it's not high
enough I go how much is it
she says 165 000.
and when you're brand new like Jack you
haven't been in any of these
appointments could you talk a lady from
165 down to 150 that's about to retire
ah almost certainly no hell no like hell
no I'm like what do I do here so I came
to the conclusion I couldn't help her so
I told her I couldn't help her and as I
was walking out of the house I stop
and I say look I can't help you I can't
offer that much money but is there
anything I can do to help you and she's
like I'm so confused you want to help me
but you don't want to buy my house
what are you a Boy Scout and I go yeah
actually I'm a Boy Scout I'm an eagle
scout and I was like all proud of it
because when I was growing up my mom's
like you have to get your Eagle Scout
because one day somebody's gonna ask you
are you an eagle scout and you're going
to be able to say yes I'm like I've
never been asked I know we're an eagle
scout no I said I've never been asked
everyone like yeah but you're still
young gram you got plenty you got plenty
of time you can just do it you can still
do it all right so I said yeah I'm an
eagle scout and she goes what do you
what do you what could you do to help me
I go I got Crews I got my guys they can
come load your truck we can do whatever
your retiring school teacher I love my
school teachers she's like you really
want to help me I go yeah I want to help
you and so what ends up happening is
she goes you really want to help me yep
I want to help you so she walks me to
her backyard she opens up the sliding
glass door and she shows me these three
bunnies that are Flemish bunnies if you
guys Google Flemish bunny they're this
big like literally the size of a
four-year-old child that's cool weird
yeah in Arizona right it's hot 122
degrees so I'm like what do you want me
to do about this and she says this is
why I haven't sold my house
I my granddaughter bought these for me
I've been taking care of them I don't
know what to do with them I can't take
them with me to Oregon where I'm
retiring and I gotta get rid of them so
long story short
I call my mom my mom comes and picks up
the Flemish bunnies takes the Flemish
bunnies and takes them to my mom's
little farm
and Janie's like wow you solved my
problem this is amazing are you sure you
can't pay me 170 000 for the house I go
no I can't and she's thinking like any
moment I'm gonna try and manipulate her
into a lower price right so I go home
two weeks later I get a call from Janie
and she says hey I'm a school teacher I
always give my kids homework and I give
myself homework today's the day I got to
make a decision to sell the house and
I'm I decide I'm gonna sell the house to
you
I'm like okay but I can't pay you 165. I
don't I ca she goes I don't care what
your price is you're the only person I
met with 15 people before you and 15
people after you everybody came in with
a clipboard and a beaut like criticized
my house people tell me they can't list
the house unless I fixed the windows
they told me basically this house should
be boarded up
and she goes I whatever your offer is
I'll take it and so I bought the house
for 150 000. I Dro I picked up Bethany
went up there filled out the paperwork
bought the house for 150 Grand and I
went and made 25 grand for basically
three hours worth of work and I was like
how do I do this more so do you
wholesale it I wholesaled it to Bethany
got it because I told Bethany I was like
I don't want to be in a Fix and Flip I
got enough flips going on for other
people and so I I assigned it to Bethany
and I walked away with 25 Grand I'm
surprised she she met with that many
people and not one person would offer
her more than the 165. if Bethany's
willing to pay 175 for it yeah it's
interesting Bethany ended up selling the
house for a little over
um 400 Grand and so I look at the deal
too and I was like that's a great deal
so I made 25 Grand Bethany ended up
netting like 50 60 000 bucks on the
house
um but typically like the people the
only people that are interfacing with a
homeowner in that situation are not
actual fix and flippers this is the
thing about that industry that nobody
talks about it's either a real estate
agent or a wholesaler people that are
fixing and flipping are too busy fixing
and flipping they're not out marketing
they're talking to agents and they're
talking to wholesalers to get their
deals so Bethany was the actual fix and
flipper she was willing to pay more
money because she was direct to seller
in that essentially in that situation
right the 165 came from a wholesaler who
was going to turn around and sell it for
175 to somebody else I just didn't know
it at the time I didn't really
understand wholesale at the time even
though I just did a wholesale deal so
here's what happens I make 25 Grand on
that and then I made I got three more
deals that month in my first month I
made 50 Grand in my first month I'm like
holy crap this is how I got into
creative Finance
so I go to the title company open escrow
on all of these transactions and there's
a lady named Eileen Brown that I end up
meeting Eileen Brown has been in the
Trent in the industry for 48 years like
the OG knows everything about everything
and she's like where where did you come
from like you opened four contracts I've
never seen you before did you used to
open your title stuff over at a
different company I was like nope these
are my first four contracts like she's
like in 30 days like who are you and I
told her about the bunny story and she's
like oh my gosh this is great like where
are your leads coming from and I go I
tell her and she goes so you have more
leads I go yeah
but I can't help them
she goes what do you mean what's going
on with the leads and I go well the
other leads I have I got 50 leads that
month I got four contracts
and I said well the other 44 people that
I have that are leads don't have any
equity and some of them want too much
money
right as an agent I'm sure you listed
houses for people that are just like I
want to sell my house for 300 Grand over
what retail is and you're like dude what
are you talking about right and like we
just closed a 20 million apartment
complex in Springfield Illinois a couple
weeks ago I paid a million over retail
but I did no money down seller finance
on 265 units this stock like Eileen
Brown goes go back to those people that
want too much money or the people that
don't have equity and bring those to me
and I'll show you how to do subject two
and seller finance and I'm like subject
what and sell it what's seller finance
so she white boards all these things out
for me shows shows me that I could go
back to those leads that essentially
were dead for me and I got an extra four
contracts that month just from creative
finance and I walked through with her
and I found that
the amount of bunnies I could find
essentially like all these people had a
different version of bunnies that were
keeping them from selling Eileen taught
me how to go find all the bunnies help
the people that don't have Equity that
are going to foreclosure like Maricopa
County if you guys look up I don't know
how Vegas is but Maricopa County where
I'm at three people get foreclosed on
every day
and I look at those people like you're
getting foreclosed on your credit's
going to be destroyed let me come in and
fix your credit let me take over the
existing debt I'll turn it into a cash
flowing property and I'll rebuild your
credit I didn't know that that existed
at that moment until Eileen told me I
had to lay down on the ground I was so
blown away I was like how is this
possible she was like well I've been
doing it for 48 years I'm like this is
happening she's like yeah I do two or
three of them every single week I was
like no way
so I did that for four or five months
and then I I got my first due on sale
Clause called on me I got I called an
attorney the attorney's like oh yeah
this is easy I've ran into these this is
what we do boom boom boom okay so what's
the worst thing that could happen in
these do on sale class that's it
boom and I lit the world on fire bought
300 single-family homes and 1500
multi-family doors
all creative Finance so what's your
pitch when you walk in to the homeowner
the pitch is pretty easy are they all
behind on their payments no like this no
like the fir like one of the best seller
finance stories I could tell you is I
got so good at finding the bunnies for
the wholesalers and agents that agents
would call me and go hey my client wants
too much money they don't need the money
they just want a really high purchase
price again seller finance is typically
gain related and subject to is pain
related right they have a painful
situation seller finance is like I just
they're greedy and justifiably it's at
their house right so I would get
wholesalers that would call me and I got
a wholesaler called me like four years
in and this is just a good store that
tells you how this is all structured and
exactly how the flow is
wholesaler's name is Tom Tom calls me up
he goes hey I've got a property on 1906
South 78th Place
seller looked at Zillow and the Zillow
price is 100 Grand she wants 110 grand
for the property this happens all the
time so as a wholesaler what do you have
to pay uh what as a wholesaler what do
you have to buy that up for 80 75 no I'm
way lower than that because the house
isn't worth 800 Grand it could be worth
100 Grand if it was renovated right so
as a wholesaler you would have to pay
probably 40 45 so Tom is like bewildered
he's like how the freak am I going to
buy pay your house for 100 grand he
meets me at Aria like a little real
estate investor Meetup and he says
you're the creative Finance guy right so
if I ever have a weird lead I can call
you go yep and that became my business I
just went on other people's appointments
that had impossible leads so Tom calls
me up he goes hey you want to come meet
with uh Susan is her name so I go to the
appointment I meet with Dale and Susan
we meet in their little house they had
they have tenants in the house but
they've told the tenants to leave for a
little bit so I could come in and tour
the property
standing in the kitchen
and I said same thing I said to Janie
Munson four years prior said what's kept
you from selling the house she says
everybody keeps lowballing me and I want
to retire we're sick of dealing with the
tenants what do we call those people we
call them tired landlords they're done
like they're not great operators they're
sick of switching out toilets and light
fixtures and stuff
so
um she goes I just keep getting lowball
they go let me guess and this is my
pitch this is how I convert from a cash
conversation to a creative conversation
I go
um
well let me guess you're probably
getting offers around 40 maybe 50 000
bucks and she's like yeah how did you
know I go because if I was going to buy
the house for cash I would probably
offer that same amount as well
and you see what I did there I'm like if
I was going to offer that much if I was
going to offer cash I'd offer that much
too she's like what do you mean you're
not going to offer me cash I go no
if you were going to sell the house for
40 50 Grand you would have sold it to
somebody before I got here you want more
money so I typically will match
somebody's price as long as they give me
terms
and she's like what's term she has no
idea what terms are and so I tell I told
her a story about my first transaction I
ever did F1 was an F-150 as a contractor
I had an F-150 that had like
320 000 miles on it so I went to Kelly
Blue Book and I go what's this truck
worth
she says or Kelly Blue Book says five
thousand bucks
so I go put on Kelly Blue Book what
offers am I getting at 5 000 bucks what
uh what price Jack three yeah
two and a half for a grand
because you're smart but my my highest
offer was 3 100 bucks sure but that
truck was being used for my construction
company so it made me more money being
used I and I was willing to deal with
the headaches it was giving me versus
giving letting somebody buy it for 3 100
bucks
so I tell Susan just like I tell every
seller the same the same story when I
was going on appointments now I got a
team that does that but I tell Susan I
go I go on Kelly Blue Book I get people
calling me lowballing me just like
you're getting lowballed right now and I
decide to go get belligerent just like
you Susan like I go belligerent I go all
right I'm going to change my listing
from five grand to 10 grand because then
in that situation if I do get lowballed
I'll get lowballed at five grand but
what happened is nobody even saw my post
nobody looked at it people laughed at it
probably didn't even message me and um a
couple months later didn't sell my wife
comes in and she goes hey sweetheart
like is there any way you can get this
truck out of the driveway I gotta like
kind of move around it to get into the
garage every time
like what do you want me to do
and she's like why don't you take
payments for the truck
I was like oh my gosh that's so freaking
genius so I literally put my truck back
on Craigslist I changed one thing I say
F-150 will take payments so I say Susan
do you think I sold my truck for 10 000
bucks
cheers probably I go I sold it for
twelve thousand five hundred dollars
with a thousand dollars down
and I go that's what terms is
and she's like I'll do that all day long
and she goes okay so you'll give me 110
I go I will come up to 110 as long as
you give me terms that make sense for me
and so that was a deal I got zero
dollars down zero percent interest you
can pull up the the deed of trust that
we created
most of my seller finance deals are zero
percent seller finance because I'm
matching their number and a lot of them
are no down payments obviously that that
requires some um credibility right they
got to see my track history they got to
see who I am but the average deal I
probably put five percent down no credit
check I've never had my credit checked
on a single deal nobody's ever asked for
my job history nobody's ever asked for
my tax returns not a single time out of
the last 700 transactions I've done
creative Finance not one time everyone
goes through title we get Title
Insurance on every single one depending
on the state like Atlanta I buy a lot of
deals in Atlanta always goes through a
closing attorney in Atlanta because
they're an attorney State not a title
state
and that's what I've just focused on I
focused on if I don't have them if I
don't have money how do I buy a piece of
real estate and I thought like the radio
stuff like no money down and all that
kind of stupid crap I was like dude just
freaking scam artists out here as a blue
collar contractor I just was like I
heard it on the radio as I'm cruising
around and like all of that's is fake
but I can tell you can look up any
address you can look at this address by
the time you guys list this I'll be the
owner of this property or by the time
you guys put this podcast up this house
on 8110 Cerro Medina San Antonio Texas
I get it gets brought to me today I will
be the owner tomorrow in one day that's
how fast creative Finance is I don't
have to go through credit checks I don't
have to go through appraisals I don't
have to go through inspections I will
become the owner of this property today
that one lady how long of a term do you
get
um oh with her yeah that one is 20 20
years zero percent interest in fairness
she would have been better off just
taking the 50 and investing it yeah but
we're not talking about Graham Stefan's
the world right we're talking about
people that can't even handle one
um they can't even handle one rental
right at all so these are tired
landlords it's I bought a 43 unit last
year a 30 unit a 30 unit a 50 unit 109
unit 138 unit and a 256 unit all the
exact same way all the exact same way we
had when we were negotiating a 300 unit
on like really close to the strip it was
a zero down zero percent seller finance
deal too
um but I we're gonna have to follow up
with that one how much is that one
um that one's like 50 mil oh wow yeah my
biggest deal I closed last year was 109
million dollar deal in in North Carolina
Charlotte North Carolina 400. partner
with people on that I used to when I was
brand new right so what I would do is I
would go to people like Graham Stefan
who have a fancy Patek watch and I go
hey man you obviously have money can you
be my private money lender in the very
beginning I didn't have the credibility
to entice them to be my private money
lenders I had to entice them to be My
Equity partner so I would do that they'd
come in with the down payment and the
closing costs and maybe the furniture
cost to get the Airbnb up and going if
that was my strategy but then I got
credibility I learned how to raise money
that I didn't have to give away Equity
so I haven't given away equity on a real
estate deal in probably five years what
rate are you getting for uh private
money so on my flips I get 10 no points
on my long-term
um stuff where I go all right I'm buying
it like this sub 2 deal let's let's give
this as an example if I was brand new
what I would do is my total cost to get
this deal
um the guy who's bringing it to me it's
an assignment so this is cool you can
assign these sub two deals okay so uh
he'll get paid 10 grand as an assignment
fee the
closing costs will be three grand and
then I'll probably spend five grand
cleaning up the property and getting
getting it rented out so I'll be into it
let's say 20 grand if I'm brand new
this is what's cool about creative
Finance too it if you were a real estate
agent and somebody comes to you Graham
and says I want to buy an investment
property tomorrow
guess what they have to have not only
you have to have good credit job history
tax returns and everything under the sun
the loan officer is going to ask for and
then they're gonna ask for more two
weeks later then they're gonna ask for
more two weeks later you've been through
this a bunch of times like dude how much
more information do you need just get
the freaking loan done the worst part
about that is that the down payment has
to come from their own sources
in Creative Finance I can get a private
money lender to bring that money in
nobody's gonna nobody cares where my
down payment came from right so somebody
will come in with that 20 grand and I'll
pay them 12 interest and then I'll
utilize the cash flow to pay them off
for probably the first year maybe two
years
so I give them 12 interest on their 20
grand that makes sense so how many like
doors or houses do you have now close to
1800 how do you manage all that so I
have a team I have a I have a Molly
everybody that knows me knows Molly
Molly's my CEO and then I've got an
asset manager and then I got a team but
when I first started it was you when you
when you get up to like 20 rentals you
can primarily manage that yourself like
you and maybe your spouse and it gets to
a point I think you're at 10 that you go
dude this is like starting to become a
job and you Outsource that to a property
management company so I have property
management companies that we Outsource
it to I've never started a property
management company it was never
something I wanted to do and so I have
property management companies like in
North Carolina I have a lot of assets
Florida Texas Atlanta specifically
um Nevada I have a bunch of properties
here in Arizona so I have property
management companies there and then I
have an asset manager that manages them
and then I have a CEO that manages her
got it that makes sense and what do you
look for is it cash flow or do you go
for appreciation I don't care about
appreciation I tell people all the time
that Equity comes Equity goes but the
cash always flows so like look what
happened in that this last year the the
what happened was when I first started I
was like how do I get cash flow and then
when I understood the tax benefits of
buying real estate I actually care more
about the depreciation right there's a
lot of people that you hang out with
that all these rich people that get
these big swaths of money and these guys
are giving away 40 50 of their income to
the IRS I'm not paying any in any of my
income to I don't pay any income tax I
pay consumption tax an employee employee
tax and property tax and all that stuff
but my money that I make I don't pay any
income on it because I use real estate
to offset that so the main thing I care
about is this a property that will cash
flow number one and number two I care
about the debt that comes with it and
then number three I care that it's going
to give me the tax benefits that I need
to pay no tax to pay zero dollars in tax
what do you think of the current market
right now it's unbelievable for me
think about it all these people the the
it's like the Golden Age of creative
Finance because people went out in 2019
to 20 21 and 22 and they obtained all
these two three and four percent
interest rate loans now the market
change and shifts and people that are in
foreclosure right now or people that are
going through a job change or whatever
it is this is what's happening if let's
say I buy a property that is Cash
flowing 300 bucks and all of a sudden my
rent rates come down what do I do with
that asset
one I either a I don't cash flow on it
which is not a that's not a newbie
strategy that's a strategy I can
withstand or b i divert and do a
different exit strategy go midterm I do
short term I do sober living I do
something along those lines and I
amplify my cash flow then why isn't the
strategy just doing that from the
beginning like just doing all sober
living all for me yeah because like if
that's your alternative to make more
money we need to start with that all
right so I started with Airbnb this is a
great question so I started with Airbnb
because I thought okay a lot more cash
flow this is super exciting I'm going to
go this route I think Airbnb is so over
hyped it's ridiculous so I get in I get
up to 75 airbnbs and then regulation
starts setting in Atlanta and I'm like
dude I've got 15 airbnbs in Atlanta now
the regulations are coming in you have
to have a license there now and you can
only have one prop property per license
I have 15 properties
so I didn't know I had to learn through
my mistakes and so my properties in
Atlanta I kept them all but I then
diverted them to sober living you have
to kind of get educated along the way I
didn't know that from the beginning I
mean on my first deal with Janie I
didn't even know how to fill out a
contract right you got to figure these
things out along the way it's the same
thing with like real estate agents
agents don't learn how to comp a comp a
house in real estate school they got to
learn that out on out in the field it's
funny most agents are going and doing a
listing appointment and listing their
first house before they even know how to
value a property right they're listening
to their broker they're listening to
somebody else so you kind of have to
have guidance along the way to to
navigate the waters if that makes sense
so why are you comfortable sharing all
this information it sounds like you kind
of figured out the code bro I don't have
to look for deals when I teach people
how to do this like these deals are
coming to me from other people that I
taught
I go go put this on YouTube Somebody
figures out how to do it they sell me
the deal last year we bought they sell
you the deals and they assign them to me
they're doing all the work got it but
very rarely do people actually approach
you directly now
what's up homeowners yeah well
homeowners stopped I I stopped doing
postcards and billboards and all that
kind of stuff about six years ago and
what we did is we started doing cold
calling a couple like probably four
years ago did you hire people for that
yeah we we use a company called
startvirtual.com that's like they're in
the Philippines they do the cold calling
and the texting and they do the Outreach
but that's only like 30 of my deal flow
70 of my deal flow right now comes from
people that I taught whether on YouTube
or at urea or something else they go out
they go get the contract and they bring
it to me and Molly and we gobble them up
and when did that start actually taking
a significant amount probably four years
four years ago four years ago yeah I
like right now I could turn off all lead
generation and just sit here and I
turned down 80 or 90 of the deals that
get sent to me my whole inbox is is
flooded with these all over the country
and you look at them personally or is
there Molly does first filter Molly does
for the first part for the most part so
like Jimmy owl is the first guy I ever
taught how to do a sub 2 deal two and a
half three years ago I was like wow okay
if I could teach people how to do this I
don't have to go out and Prospect
anymore right it's kind of like being a
broker it's like I go teach agents how
to go do listings and I don't have to go
do listings anymore so that's what I did
I taught Jimmy ow was the first guy and
here he is now three years later still
selling me deals and he's making good
money yeah I make 10 grand on that he he
didn't have to do anything on this do
you know what's funny about this
this is this is how good Jimmy is
Jimmy didn't even find that deal
Jimmy taught learned what I taught him
went to a local Ria taught like 13 or 14
real estate agents to go hey if there's
expired listings or there's listings
that are on the market for 100 days and
they're not selling which is massive
right now days on Market have gone crazy
so if you want to go get a deal right
now you and I could go get a sub 2 deal
in Vegas in four minutes like that's how
easy this is so Jimmy teaches these
agents go he goes hey go to expired
listings or go to other agents that
can't sell their listings I'm a buyer so
now he's got agents bringing him deals
and then he assigns those to me so he's
not even the one doing the prospecting
anymore
jeez it's crazy so that he sent this to
me at 4 37 we started at five I think
this is 23 minutes before I sat down
like this is all day now the only people
that are emailing me are people that I
taught directly three years ago now
what's happened is it's kind of
compounded and my YouTube channel is at
like 150 000 subscribers now so you know
we get 5 million views a month a lot of
people learn from like I'm buying a golf
cart with creative Finance I bought a
boat with creative Finance I sold my
truck on Creative Finance I bought a Kia
on Creative Finance isn't some of that
more work than it's worth buying
yourself 100 sounds like but for some
like here's an interesting thing that
that was a complete waste of my time as
an individual think about this so I get
a camera guy
he comes in he starts working for me he
goes oh man I'm working for the sub 2
guy I'm this I'm working for everybody
knows me as a sub 2 guy right and I go
and my other videographer Eric is
standing there and goes dude you don't
even know what sub 2 means
and I and my new videographer his name's
Jose goes yeah okay well show me just
show me
so I go to the Whiteboard and I start
writing it I was like wait hold on what
would make sense to a camera guy so what
I do is I go to Craigslist I sit down on
my desk like literally 10 feet away and
I go Jose what camera what camera do you
want more than anything he goes I want
the A7 S3 I want the aperture this I
want the 50 he's saying all the stuff he
wants
so I go on Craigslist can't find it in
Arizona I go on Craigslist in LA and I
go oh cool there's a guy selling an A7
S3 with these three lenses he doesn't
have a light with it but it's all good I
go would you want me to buy this he goes
yes I go cool so the package is being
sold I think for 4 500 bucks okay
and I called the guy up right there this
is all recorded we put this on the
YouTube channel
and Eric's sitting here recording the
whole thing obviously Eric's a smart guy
I called a guy on Craigslist and I go
hey I'll pay you uh five grand for your
bundle
and the guy goes what are you talking
about five grand I got it listed for 4
500 you did it and I go well it's
because I'm going to ask you for a favor
and he says well okay what and I go it's
going to be a little bit weird but I'm a
wedding photographer which I'm not but
Jose is on the weekends I'm a wedding
photographer I don't have the money to
buy the camera equipment I know I can
make more money if I had that camera
equipment
would you let me buy that camera
equipment put an agreement together and
make you payments every time I go make
money on a wedding the guys goes yeah
you'll pay me five grand
no problem so we give them 500 bucks
down Jose goes out buys gets the camera
equipment and goes out and starts doing
stuff on the weekends is it more work
of course but it's the same thing with
when you buy a car the bank is trusting
you but what collateral do they have
right well how usually they're verifying
with your credit so they have to kind of
hang out or down payment right sometimes
yeah right so we get we give him 500
bucks it's it's not as easy when you go
watch the conversation with the guy it's
not as easy as like hey I'll give you
five grand yeah well I guess it's easier
to track down the car and repossess it
than it would be finding some some guy's
camera right so but I'm just telling you
there's nothing you can't do with
creative finance and what I the reason
why I do the golf cart stuff the reason
why I do the truck and the Kia and the
watches and stuff on Creative Finance is
just to show people that you can
literally buy anything with creative
finance and then when you really
understand like the history of all these
companies like Dupont and all these big
companies that are the biggest richest
families in the in the country they all
built their fortunes off seller finance
and creative Finance every single one of
them Walmart uses create to finance and
everything that they do and so when you
start understanding how simple it is it
seems complicated because the
terminology is there but name something
you want you want a house I'll go get
you a house with no credit check I'll
get you I'll get you a house right now
with 3.25 interest amidst everybody else
out there in the country is going I
can't get a house
I can't get a house because interest
rates are at 7.5 I'm like what do you
guys this is the greatest time in
history for me I would do that
why wouldn't you that sounds good to me
well I guess it's such a small
subsection though it's not because
there's 600 any home that's listed 600
000 houses right now Mr Cooper saying
take these mortgages anything that's
listed right now I know any agent would
just scoff at that and not dealing with
that anytime I hear anytime I hear that
from an agent I'm talking to all agents
out there all you're telling me as a
real estate investor is that you are
inexperienced and you didn't actually
learn real estate I know if I came to
that when I was at Coldwell Banker and
brought any sort of deal they would
immediately say nope we're not getting
involved too much it's because your
broker is a listing Centric broker if
you go to a broker who is dealing with
agents who are out there investing and
flipping and building stuff they'd be
like a hundred percent it I call it the
bank teller Paradox it's like you go to
a bank teller and they say sorry we have
to put your check on hold for seven days
because it's Bank policy and you're like
what are you talking about so you take
your check and you go to your branch
that they know you and they deposit and
they release the money right now have
you ever had that happen to you okay you
guys I've ran a big construction
companies so it's happened to me a
hundred times I've learned same thing
with title companies I go to a title
company they go what's this what's
seller finance they don't there's agents
that don't even know what seller finance
is
and you go go on landwatch.com right now
there's 12 000 listings on on
landwatch.com just on seller finance
twelve thousand go on Vegas's MLS right
now 200 listings right now on seller
finance subject to and seller finance
just because agents don't know it now
here's the thing I'll argue with agents
the average agent makes less than forty
thousand dollars a year what am I taking
their advice for the average agent 90
plus percent of them don't even make a
full-time living as an agent so the last
person I'm taking real estate advice
from is an agent unless they are a top
earner and when I talk to a top earner
agent they go yeah we can figure this
out so the strategy is you go to right
now go to the MLS filter down to
listings that are over 100 days and you
tell the the agent hey I'm I am willing
to pay full price would your seller be
willing to let me take over payments
probably fifty percent of the time the
agent's not going to know what you're
talking about so what you do is you
follow up guess what you do again you
follow up again the next week you know
this when you did listings you don't
land every listing you get just like I
don't call I don't call an agent or call
a homeowner that's in foreclosure and
they pick up the phone and I get the
deal immediately seventy percent of our
deals come from 13 follow-ups that was
the most important thing that I learned
in real estate was 70 percent of my
deals come from 13 follow-ups
so somebody's like I'm not ready or I'm
not this or I'm not that great no
problem I'll follow up in two weeks or
I'll follow up in 30 days or whatever it
is you want a rental property yes okay
where do you want to run a property here
in Las Vegas I mean I would also take
somewhere in the midwest okay Midwest is
too easy we're part of Midwest where do
you want to go uh Mississippi
Mississippi is very easy okay if I got
you a rental property zero down let's
say under three or under four percent
interest you would want to manage that
property or would you want to partner
with somebody that would manage it for
you uh I mean I would probably prefer to
partner with someone so I can just focus
on this podcast I will find you a
property in less than 30 days that will
not require your credit it will not
require money out of your pocket nobody
will ask for your tax history your job
history nothing and you will go through
a title company get Title Insurance in
less than 30 days what's Jack's office
if you did that I would report on it
here on the iced coffee hour guys go to
my every single address I buy it's all
reported on Public Works Jack's
obligation though so this is the
challenge right so if you want to be
somebody that jumps into the industry
you got to make a decision there's only
three ways to make money there's three
ways to make money as a real estate
investor only three wholesale Fix and
Flip or Buy and Hold
I don't know that I take you as a Buy
and Hold guy yet unless it's in your
backyard I do plan on buying a whole I
get I get that so that's why I'm saying
like if you live in Vegas why not buy a
one in Vegas because it makes people
feel more comfortable that is ideal you
know what I'm saying yeah so if you want
a Vegas deal I'll get you a Vegas deal
easy right Ryan Pineda you guys know
Ryan Pineda he's doing these deals as
well him and his team have my team do
their transaction coordination people in
the real estate industry are really
really doing it's just the agents are
not educated at school and they're not
educated by their Brokers so what
happens is where else do you get
education if you're an agent that's it
but Jack's buying this property what
does Jack do okay so yeah I feel like
you'd just be throwing me a bone at that
point I feel like I need a you know what
yeah in a situation like that like
what's Jack doing every month you can't
just do no work nothing and just get a
check for
no you would have to hire a property
management company I'll refer you one
um there might be cost to get into the
property but I could refer you a partner
there's we have a lot a lot of people
here in Vegas like
Uh Kevin show would be a really good fit
for you young guy lives here in Vegas
Kevin Cho comes in as a private money
lender in the deal or partner you're 50
50 with him he bring you bring the deal
I'll bring the deal you bring the deal
he brings the money you guys are 50 50
Partners you guys hire a property
management company you sit back and get
checks and then once a year you got to
get a report from your your uh property
management company says hey Jack just so
you know tenants leaving what do you
want to do do you want to raise the
rates we suggest you do because blah
blah blah blah you'll still have to have
involvement you probably have an hour a
month of involvement in looking at
emails and stuff like that
and then the property management company
will call you go hey we need to repair
requests we need 200 200 more fixed on
this thing your tenant punched a hole in
the wall whatever you'll have you'll
still have to have involvement are you
saying this is just a hypothetical
situation no bro I'm sure because I
would actually do this I don't know why
I just take the deal for himself why why
would he put me or Kevin yeah Kevin
why why is Graham so skeptical all the
time because I'm thinking I wouldn't do
I wouldn't want to partner with anybody
well you wouldn't but you would right in
the beginning on your first deal 100 I
also have I have money I could pitch it
towards it but why would you do it with
money if you want to learn how to do it
without money here's that's a that's a
good point you know maybe I'm just too
easy to convince which is great grandma
and I have an amazing like dichotomy I
love it I am one way and so many things
and he's the here's what I think I think
I think that's sold I think one of the
things
I think one of the smartest people on
the planet is Dave Ramsey but I think
one thing I disagree with him on is the
debt is debt conversation everybody I
know that's worth a lot of money
let's take Dave Ramsey's ability to sell
courses and sell all his back end
products out how does Dave Ramsey buy
property he says he buys property cash
but where does that cash come from it
comes from his influence and when you're
talking about your audience your
audience doesn't have influence like
that so how does your audience go out
and buy real estate they have to use
leverage Leverage is powerful and
everybody wealthy uses leverage I'll say
it's safe to say his wealth is from a
very strong income and hundred percent
of course supported by lucrative
Investments of course most and yes but
mostly by a very strong income right but
his his rhetoric of don't ever incur
debt actually puts people once incurred
debt but 15-year mortgages yeah I
believe in that yeah I believe I believe
in the lab so I I think he appeals to
the lizard brain human beings the people
that live in fear versus the people that
want to be the one or the three percent
and say I want to make half a million
dollars more a year those people need to
learn how to acquire skills not learn
how to save more money and we all you
know all know you're not gonna you're
not gonna live a good life by trying to
figure out how to not buy Starbucks now
that's one thing that does help by uh
scaling back in Starbucks I don't buy
Starbucks
I only use your coffee so
here's a good question why would I why
do I not use my own money why do you not
use your own money yeah because
because you could use it on other things
there you go so think about it so if I
can get somebody else to come in at 10
percent right
or even be an equity partner so I don't
have a payment to them and it's not
really alone it's them being a partner
but I could use my cash on wholesale or
Fix and Flip or my cash flow and I could
go buy other businesses like title
companies that have a like you go buy a
title company for 200 000 bucks you're
making 800 Grand in your first year it's
crazy so why wouldn't I just go buy more
title companies my return on my
investment is way more than 10 percent
so my question is why would I ever put
money into a flip I don't flip on the TV
show The a e TV show that we're on
um
all those houses we don't use any of our
own money nothing zero zilch nothing why
would I use my own money for Real Estate
when there's all real estate is such a
secure investment because it's solid
it's tangible you can put a lien on the
property it's easy to put money to go
get money so why would you ever use your
own money I'm just curious because I do
understand what Graham skepticism is
coming of course it's like for me I
actually no I don't I don't know where
the skepticism but here's the thing I
think if you understood the exact reason
for the skepticism you probably would
understand so this guy Kevin right why
would he partner with me when he could
just be doing this on his own or why
would you just not take this deal
yourself like what is the benefit of my
presence you got that's an interesting
thing you guys you guys don't know me
too well so you don't know like my
community and how strong we are and like
you go if I show up right now if I go
hey guys we're gonna go to a ice cream
thing before I go to the airport I have
300 people show up we have a go Giver
Network everybody's always helping each
other out it is absolutely insane people
help each other other to help each other
out first and foremost and collaboration
over competition is way more powerful so
the other thing is it's fun
yeah but this is a business route I I
actually are more I know this obviously
it's benefiting me so it would make
sense that I'll air more on your side
but I would say just as a philosophical
standpoint I do air more on your side I
do love the Buddy stuff the Friendship
stuff where it doesn't necessarily have
to be very transactional I've said this
to Graham before in the past one point
of contention he and I have is he is a
very much more transactional type person
yeah you need that you need that in a
good balance right like a good marriage
in both business and and relationship
has has that perfect balance for sure
but for me I'm on the more aggressive
side my partner so all my partners I'm a
Visionary so I'm more aggressive on
let's go buy more let's go raise more
money but I have a counterbalance in all
my businesses too I have operators right
I have nine businesses that I have and
each one of those businesses has an
operator partner that is a gram I need
grams that are like hold on hold on we
bought 40 properties last month let's
not buy properties for three more months
let's stabilize these before you go buy
another one and I'm like but there's
deals out there so right now I'm turning
down deals because I you can't stabilize
a thousand properties in one month you
figure out a good Pipeline and then you
have to say no to stuff and when you say
notice stuff guess what you do
you just say that's not a good deal no
because you have to understand that
every one of these deals that you're
saying no to has bunnies in each one of
these stories there's a lady that's
retiring there's somebody in foreclosure
there's somebody in a bad situation it's
very unlike traditional real estate the
off-market world the traditional real
estate world is like I'm gonna call an
agent but there's a whole subset massive
amount massive massive amount there's
over 400 000 transactions going on every
single month that are off-market deals
both either people we won't get into
that's a whole nother conversation that
nobody even sees that is a real estate
agent so real estate agents have their
blinders on and they go well where are
all these deals Mike
not paying you commission that's where
they are they're paying me can you share
with so many units what your monthly
take-home is after paying off all the
debt like what's the net profit every
month uh so after payrolls like Molly
yeah all that kind of stuff right uh
you're probably double six figures so
close to 200 000 a month yeah and what
does that equate to in terms of a dollar
amount of real estate
um so the total amount of money the
total amount of real estate that we own
is somewhere around 300 million
but again yeah but a lot of those are
paying down a lot of the a lot of the
money that's coming in is not cash flow
to me a lot of that money is that's
coming in is paying down the debt right
because I have payments I'm paying to
sellers now we're bringing in a lot of
money but those payments that come in
I'm then paying my sellers who are my
bank right and then my net cash flow is
completely different than what I
actually bring for sure right do you do
commercial at all or you stay away from
me I don't know commercial very well so
I have right now I have a deal in Carson
City
um which is near Reno I think so I have
a deal in Carson City that is a seller
finance storage unit and I'm like okay I
could do that I don't have anything in
Carson City that's a problem is that
determining and turning down why I won't
buy in certain areas right now I'm at a
point where I have enough real estate in
15 different markets that if it comes to
me outside of that market I'm just
wholesaling it but I have a storage unit
that came to me this morning Carson City
and I go oh it's seller finance 10 down
seller finance storage unit I don't
really have tenants and I'm dealing with
like toilets and trash and all that kind
of stuff I will probably buy that deal
but it will be my first storage unit
deal and what's the return on that net
income per year 60 000. so after you pay
the seller off after you pay the taxes
and insurance the net income would be
sixty thousand dollars is what he's what
he's equating so I mean one storage unit
on seller finance is 60 Grand a month or
60 Grand a year for most people they
could probably have their wife or
themselves probably quit their job and
just go full-time real estate with that
60 Grand that's on one deal yeah now
does that include Management on that um
yeah eight percent Management on that is
what he assumes in his p l here okay is
that realistic for a storage center I
think so doesn't it don't they usually
require that someone like be on site I
think it's a smaller one so the ones
that are bigger and they have like RV
storage and stuff like that I don't know
I sounds like I know a lot but I
actually don't know a lot I know enough
about RV storage facilities because as a
contractor I used to build them for
people but I didn't I've never owned one
so I know what happens I know the mom
and pop ones that are like 100 units or
smaller typically don't have an on-site
manager the ones that have more than
that do or the ones that have RV storage
where somebody has to pull in and back
in a lot of times they need somebody to
make sure people aren't backing into
people's boats and stuff like that but I
I just have stayed in my Lane between I
stayed in my lane for a long time on
single family I was afraid of
multi-family but now that I understand
multi-family I'm like wow this is
actually a lot easier than single family
once you have the credibility and the
resources to manage the problems and why
do you invest in the areas that you do
uh part of the reasons I did is because
that's where my deals were coming from
okay like Atlanta I the first deal I
bought in Atlanta
I was I flew out there and I was
speaking and somebody that I was
speaking in the audience was like I have
a deal so I left I went and bought I
went to the property go okay I'll buy
the deal and now that I own a property
in Atlanta and I knew that it's an
appreciating Market I started buying
more deals in Atlanta so wherever I got
a deal in my first year or two years and
I kind of set these strongholds like
politically I wanted to be in areas that
were landlord friendly and I wanted to
be in areas that had a population growth
of at least point zero eight percent a
year I'm sorry point eight percent so
just under one percent a year and if
they had population growth and good
politics I'll buy there now I'm at a
point where I don't need more markets I
just want more properties in those
markets so I say no to everything else
got it yeah just out of curiosity I was
doing the numbers in my head so if you
let's say the longest loans that you
have on all any of your properties is 50
years then wouldn't that make that after
50 years his lapse and you don't change
anything you'd have 300 million dollars
right technically in cash way more than
that well because
but then you're making 200 000 a month
which is two two and a half million
dollars a year about
if you times that by by 50 that is not
300 million so you're just you're gonna
continue selling on the properties early
assuming that I don't think what I'll
probably do and I'm I'm newer right I'm
in the I'm in this part of the business
less than 10 years so I don't know what
the next 10 years looks like and I know
that when you have kids things change
when you get married things change when
you buy when you decide hey I'm 40 years
old things change right so when you were
before you moved to Vegas you lived a
different different lifestyle than you
lived today you made different decisions
than you did today I don't know what
tomorrow holds all I know right now is
that I want to continue to um control
and own more real estate and my goal now
is I look at my c-suite so my c-suite
like CFO CEO CEO all the people that are
on my team I look at them and I go how
do I make you guys worth 20 million
dollars and so I have to turn around and
buy enough real estate that justifies
them becoming worth that that's my goal
now and sometimes you're going to switch
out with assets like we had a 20 unit
deal that we bought a couple years ago
that we went through the inspection
everything was fine and then a couple
years later we had a sewage backup and
we found out that like five years prior
they basically they didn't literally
duct tape but they basically duct taped
the Sewer back together we didn't catch
it and we had to go in and dump 300 000
into the property and I was like
what else do I do we not know about this
property and I offloaded the property I
sold it so in those situations I'll
offload a property but now I've got a
1031 exchange that cash that I have in
that property into another asset so I
prefer not to be in that situation right
you probably as an agent you ran into
investors that would go I'm selling this
asset but now I have a timeline I have
to roll that money into another asset or
else I get hit with taxes that's another
great thing about creative Finance
creative Finance you can do a delayed
1031 exchange the seller let's say a
seller sells the property to me his
payments that I paid to him can actually
be a 1031 exchange over 30 years
isn't that freaking cool how is that how
does that work it has to go through with
a an exchange intermediary so a licensed
person that does the 1031 stuff and it
bypasses all the regulation for the 1031
in a cash transaction in a creative
transaction the 1031 can be delayed over
whatever 20 years 30 years 50 years
wouldn't that would mean you would
eventually have to buy yeah yeah he
would have that he would have to do
something so you're saying let's just
say I sell a building for 10 million
dollars and your agreement is I'll pay
you a million dollars a year for 10
years yeah so that million dollars a
year what goes into an account no it
goes It goes he he does have to identify
an asset okay so it has to go towards an
asset he can't just receive the money it
has to go to an asset he's identified
but those payments can be justified
towards this 1031 even two years three
years four years five years down the
road does that make sense yes so the
just closing on that second property
he's already closed on it he just had to
go and get debt on it does that make
sense so he goes and gets a loan he does
whatever but my payments to him can be
identified as payment towards that
property that's where that money goes
and that will satisfy the 1031. okay so
he's still he still identifies the
property the same way you would identify
a property in a regular 1031 but he
doesn't have to have all the money to
put into that deal as of today he can
say hey 1031 intermediary the person
that's licensed to do all this stuff
this these payments are going to come to
me for the next 20 30 years or whatever
it is I want those payments to be
attributed to this property that I've
already identified sure okay yeah
there's all sorts of really cool things
you can do okay so where is your thought
in terms of where the Market's going
over the next few years so I told
everybody that wholesalers don't want to
hear this but I have friends that are
wholesalers and in January say guys
we're going to be we're gonna have a
bumpy ride and people are going to get
fired people are going to get laid off
people that are loan officers and you
guys are in the mortgage anybody in the
mortgage industry is going to get
hammered if you're a real estate agent
your days on Market you're gonna 5X
and people didn't want to hear that
because they don't understand interest
rates and how they actually affect the
market no there's so much demand there's
so much demand actually you and I talked
about this like yeah but like interest
rates dude like it's going to impact
people's affordability is a big deal so
I predicted last year that we were going
to lose 30 percent we didn't I thought
we were going to lose way more I thought
it was gonna be way worse than it was
um I think interest rates are going to
go up two more times this year the FED
is specifically said we are not lowering
rates until we're at this point so I
think that we're going to have another
decline of probably 12 to 15 percent
Nationwide and then hopefully it
stabilizes in 2024. got it are there any
areas that you think that you would stay
away from I stay for as so if I'm a
wholesaler I can wholesale anywhere from
an agent I can be an agent anywhere if
I'm fixing and flipping I Can Fix and
Flip anywhere if I'm buying and holding
I stay away from states that don't like
landlords
um but I also think that there's certain
areas that are going to get hit way
harder than anywhere else and those are
typically the tertiary markets like the
the smaller markets like a Corpus
Christi is going to get hit harder way
more than a Dallas or Reno is going to
get harder way more than a Vegas is
Right Vegas has way more demand here now
Reno has like Tesla and a bunch of stuff
up there but it doesn't justify not
getting hit Tesla's been there long
enough it's not like they have a bunch
of jobs moving in
Arizona we have
rivian and these big companies moving in
and investing billions and billions and
Intel is tripling their size in Arizona
I think Arizona actually will be
somewhat insulated from the economic hit
but I don't think we're gonna have a
meltdown I think that there is enough
demand I think the FED has actually done
a good job
um
what do I know at the end of the day
other than I'm I'm happy because now
there's a lot of people just giving me
their mortgages because they're
underwater and that's what I want I want
more more mortgages right or I want to
assign more mortgages because think
about this too you have friends that are
loan officers you I don't know if you
guys ever have loan officers on here no
okay they're too boring I guess I don't
know so I was a loan officer and um for
a couple years and I learned that 50 of
people that apply for a mortgage get
declined 50 so what's cool about
creative Finance is that I can assign I
can go get a mortgage from somebody else
like that house I showed you in Texas
City I for a moment I was like should I
turn into uh should I turn into a
midterm rental or should I assign it to
an end buyer I don't have to assign a
deal to a fix-in flipper I can assign a
deal to an end buyer think about all the
end buyers out there that are like I
can't buy a house right now
so for me this is like the Golden Age of
creative Finance I think for the next 24
months I'll have a Heyday and I I'm
buying more properties and I can even
handle so how much how much debt do you
technically have then uh probably 250
255 million something like that does
that not stress you out at all look at I
mean look at anybody with wealth name
any company that has anybody that you've
had on the podcast acts as real wealth
not like I'm worth a couple million
bucks sure they all have debt that is a
powerful thing powerful thing and if my
average interest rate is at three maybe
three and a half percent I think maybe
hormozy has been the only person without
debt
it wasn't even like a financial decision
I don't think he's opposed he was just
like right you do look like you sleep
very well at night very very well you
still like hydrate or something you
don't even need an aura to track your
sleep like okay tell me about this
ordering so yeah
check this out so I've got this ring
yeah I've obviously been married a long
time but this ring creates a callus on
my finger you can see it and so somebody
showed me the aura ring the other day I
was like dude those are pretty dope so
you're thinking about replacing your
wedding ring with an aura ring yeah
it is a little bit bulky I mean I wear
it every single day you basically will
not catch me not wearing this but yeah
it just measures the basically the
amount of sleep that you get okay so you
measure your sleep what how does that
help you like what do you do with that
data do you look at it oh I didn't drink
enough water to improve your sleep
because it's hard to know exactly how
well you're sleeping without actually
seeing it on a sheet like you can feel
well rested but I also think like the
next day a lot of that's in your head
right so like if you tell yourself oh I
slept yeah well you're gonna have a lot
of energy or if you tell yourself like I
think I had a sleepless night but you
don't really know because you're kind of
in and out of sleep you're gonna have a
bad performance I think that's been the
biggest thing for me is a lot of the
time it'll be in my head and it's just
like oh I didn't get a good night's
sleep last night but uh we got the aura
ring while I got it I charge it every
day so that's why you don't see me
wearing it right now but it's been
really interesting to see I found that I
get the best night of sleep and it gives
you like a sleep score I get so happy
when it's above 90 like 100 is like a
perfect day to sleep when you get above
90 you get this like so what if you get
below 90. what do you do you do
something about me below 85 is like I
generally don't do as well the next day
if I get a sleep score below 85 and
usually I found that if I go to bed
before 11 30. there you go wake up
I'll give you some around 7 30. I want
to hear this yeah another thing is there
it measures the amount of wake ups that
you have in the middle of the night and
I noticed that when I wear earplugs the
amount of wake ups that I have
drastically decreases so you basically
can like split test certainly I look at
people that sleep with their earbuds in
like have my camera guys travel with me
I'm like how are you sleeping with
earbuds in but not earbuds but your
plugs oh ear plugs yeah yeah so just
basically muting all noise yeah that
will drastically decrease the amount of
wake ups that I have which is really
important because wake UPS can pull you
out of very deep sleep which is hard to
fall into and the deep sleep like REM
sleep is where you get most of your
energy the following day okay that's
great data and there's a bunch of other
cool data like it gives you your
temperature I remember my housemate he
noticed on his graph every single day
his temperature was increasing a little
bit he's like what's going on a few days
later he was sick now he could have
taken precautionary measures once he saw
his body that's freaking cool exactly
and on top of that it measures like wait
hold on this measures your your RAM and
your body temperature yeah it basically
divides up your sleep and yeah it
measures a bunch of stuff imagine the
amount of steps that you take in a day
the distance traveled so if I play yeah
calories burn so if I it's basically
like an Apple Watch but in a ring form
also with that's like way more
comfortable for like a married dude that
thing makes so much freaking sense I
would honestly I would strongly
recommend it to you I've been planning
on getting one for a super long time so
where do I go again or a ring
we did not even plan for this to happen
but we appreciate Aura I love their
product I literally wear it all the time
okay
one thing I will say you should get it I
will uh is it for the most part I don't
drink and I went to bed and I think I
had maybe like two drinks or something
like that went to bed horrible night of
sleep and it shows your REM sleep was
like next to nothing and the times that
I was awake it like shows you these
Peaks when like you wake up it's just
like peek peek peek I didn't even
realize it so if I have a drink and I go
to bed it just screws up my sleep and it
shows you like where you wake up I don't
even remember any of it but apparently I
woke up like four times that's freaking
cool yeah the coolest part is just split
testing stuff like wearing like
something to cover up your eyes so it's
pitch black and you see oh how does this
affect my sleep does it make it more
efficient less efficient same as the
earplugs actually you start you um when
we started the podcast you said you were
sleep deprived because you guys were jet
lagged and stuff coming from awesome
sleep jackets you can see my sleep
a competitive part of the app where you
can like bring your buddies in and
you're competing and you get like points
at the end of the week that has been one
of the best like surprising byproducts
of having this ring is that it makes me
competitive about my sleep that's
freaking I'm sure Grandma's experience
that's some adult stuff right what do
you have looking at the units for you
um before I buy them
um so before we buy them if it's a
multi-family deal we'll typically hire
an inspector to go and take a look at
the property or the person who brought
the deal to me because these multi most
of the multi-family deals that I'm doing
people are bringing them to me and I
paid them to be my boots on the ground
FaceTime me do all that kind of stuff
but they're not even FaceTiming me
anymore they FaceTime Molly or somebody
on my team it's pretty good that's I
mean that's isn't that the goal of the
business is to like not be involved the
fact that you just brought that up man
because this is one of the most like
contended on topics of this entire
podcast the viewers love it some viewers
like it some viewers don't but it's
about yeah like the reason that you want
to build up a business or the reason of
continuing to build a business is
ideally one day to take a step back or
it's at least move in that direction I'm
I don't know is is that you guys
disagree with this yes kind of I like to
be very Hands-On with everyone okay so
here's I'm maybe a difference between
even you two I'm I love working and you
love working too we love working I'm
sure I don't want to stop working I just
want to work on new things that I can
learn that's it so what I do do is I go
okay like this new thing that Arman
who's behind the scene right here
Berkeley educated super smart guy the
reason he's with me is because I've
gained resources and education that have
presented New Opportunities and now
we've got Mr Cooper basically saying hey
we'll give you these these mortgages
we'll pay you to take these mortgages
off our our books and I'm sitting here
going okay how do we do that how do we
technically handle that many properties
and I want to expand my mind and try new
things and venture out and leave my
businesses operating the way they're
currently operating
I don't I don't want to be in them every
day but I still want to enjoy being able
to step in the office and say hi to
everybody but I want to be out building
new businesses yeah right that makes
perfect sense I'm not the
go to the mountains and retire kind of
guy or hang out on the beach kind of guy
I just want to learn new stuff that's it
new people new things new experiences
every single day I think that's huge for
for me personally like I know for a fact
like if I do something for too long I'll
just get tired of it Graham on the other
hand like he has been doing the main
Channel thing like the same thing same
format I could eat the same thing every
day and be totally fine we need the
grams of the world we do yeah they keep
the world okay so are we gonna get you a
deal yes you want a rental 100 we'll do
it uh I would love a long-term rental I
really would okay so Airbnb the best
idea I mean why is it not the best idea
I think it's the greatest idea long-term
rental yeah I think long-term rental is
better what's cool about a mortgage is
that two years later you're going to
raise your rents a little bit four years
later you're going to raise your rents a
little bit four years later you're gonna
raise your rents a little bit now you're
cash flowing 800 900 a month but guess
what your mortgage payment is the exact
same it's fixed so you're going to
continue to cash flow more and more and
more and it compounds you also get the
the the payoff the mortgage balance gets
paid off and you build that Equity you
go get three or four or five of those I
mean think about like how much the
average person would need to buy to
completely never worry about money again
how many rentals to retire and be done
where in Vegas
like do they own them out right no well
not yet but let's say they're let's say
they're 30 years old and they're going
to retire at 60 or 65 years old how many
properties and they're probably two
three four there you go so like you buy
how old are you right now 24. bro
how old are you man I've been trying to
figure this out this entire time
yeah or somewhere around there yeah I'm
39. okay 39. you can tell in the great
the gray hair and the beard right so I
look at you and I'm like if you bought
one house a year that's it
that's it by the time you're 50 years
old your your real estate portfolio is
probably 15 million bucks I will say
this much that was actually my plan my
plan was to buy one every single year
let's buy one I bought my last house in
2021 and I was gonna buy in 2022 but the
entire Market just continually oh I got
I got a question for you to wrap up do
you believe that buying your primary
resident residence is an asset or a
liability I think it depends on the
price okay I think it depends
average first average person we're
talking average person here we're not
talking about somebody with an average
person I think it's it's an asset unless
they overspend or unless they sell after
a few I love this because I'm friends
with Grant Cardone we argue about this
over dinner I'm friends with other
people like Kiyosaki and we've argued
about this too I I think they well they
go well you should just rent because
pouring your money into your your
mortgage is not making you any money
Mike but I'm spending roughly the same
amount of money on rent and here's the
thing that happens with a rent payment
it goes up every 3 years my mortgage
payment doesn't so over the course of a
30-year mortgage I pay way less money on
my primary residence than I ever would
on rent the difference is I own
something
and so I I believe that a primary
residence is actually an asset now if
you're buying a five million home and
it's costing you 50 million or 50 000 a
year to keep it up and pay the mortgage
and it's definitely a liability but for
the average person it's an asset so your
house right now that you have it's an
asset I bought it for the reasons of
like wanting to jacket makes sense
because he could rent out the bedrooms
yeah yeah I'm doing that right now yeah
yeah so you should get a second one
that's a smaller one right the payment
on it let's say is like 1200 bucks and
what's your payment on yours right now
my Piti or yeah uh 2300 okay so if you
could find a three bed two bath in Vegas
for let's say 1300 bucks a month you
could rent it out for 1700 bucks a month
would you do that yeah but I'm just the
pit at 1300 seems oh I guess maybe with
your methods maybe it isn't yeah yeah
okay three percent two point eight
percent I'll get you I'll get you a
mortgage in less than 30 days that you
can say no to I'll get you a mortgage in
Vegas that is less than three percent
that I will present to you and you can
feel comfortable saying no
and you can then go
all right I'd rather watch you do I'll
come up to come to Vegas a dozen times a
year I'll come up let you walk through
the property you can do that you watch
me as I do it and then I'll present you
another one and you can say no to that
one too
and then the third one you'll go dude
why didn't I just do this okay that did
happen to me with Chandler David Smith
he presented me I love Chandler with
this uh
foreigners to use creative Finance I
think didn't I offer to front you that
um yeah but I wanted to buy a house
yeah and I didn't have enough money to
buy both where was the duplex here uh
Utah oh yeah that's different I mean you
wanted you I would always suggest people
should buy your primary zones it was it
was Idaho it makes the two up it was
Idaho Falls yep that's where Chandler
that I was I lived in Idaho Falls
Chandler David Smith and I are friends
but we've never met we're always dming
and talking to each other about real
estate he's such a cool guy oh he's
awesome I love the guy now I feel like I
should get you a duplex I would do a
duplex man I would do a duplex Graham if
I found you a deal would you do a deal
yeah okay we're gonna find we're gonna
find a deal okay I would honestly I
would love that that sounds really
exciting mine I want one deal I want one
home run big deal a big deal meaning
like a big house or a good cash flow uh
good cash flow low cost to get into the
deal yeah I would want something that's
probably worth like three to ten million
plus oh damn okay that's what I'm saying
like one one like and you would move
into it no no I'm just saying for to
rent out okay I could get you a seller
finance deal at three million dollars
easy I'd consider it okay if it makes
sense you would rent it out for like an
Airbnb or would you rent it out for like
a to a luxury like a celebrity no I
don't want I don't want like a house so
it would have to be like multi-family
yeah the problem is I would not sell
that to you yeah yeah those are so I
I've now spent my focus now on
multi-family so those deals uh I have a
multi-family analyst full-time on my
team and all he does is look at those
deals all day long and we are you buying
all of them I either buy them or I
wholesale them to my to people that I
that learn from me so I like how often
would you see like let's say like a 10
million dollar that one like a five to
ten million dollar property coming up
seller finance that makes sense every
day so but you can't possibly buy one
every day I can't so I either people I
assign them or wholesale them yeah the
thing he was what he was referring to
yeah what he would be doing for me is
more of a homey thing
but you can't get the homie down for
five million dollars that's not just
yeah here's what here's what I'll do
here's what I'll do on a five million
dollar deal I I would here's the
challenges you gotta have you gotta have
somebody operate that too right so what
I would do is I would let you come in on
the deal if you let me operate the deal
and let me be your partner on it I would
let you come in on it but I'm not going
to let those deals go but one more
question for you you mentioned in your
life that your life has changed in in
different categories of getting married
having kids yeah uh what have those
changes been getting married is
realizing that my wife is way more
significant than just a wife she becomes
a partner a confidante the calming
factor in my life and when you're
younger you don't know those things and
so you have to change from being a
selfish man to understanding you're in a
relationship that was hard for me
um because I'm just like go go go go go
go take over the world type of thing and
there's a balance and the great thing
that a woman brings to at least a
marriage in my traditional marriage is
that my wife brings a balance to the
kids that I don't bring right and so
that's the other thing too is that you
start seeing kids and your kids parent
things that you do they're like little
parrots and you start learning things
like oh wow I can't say that I can't act
this way I can't get on the phone and
bark at somebody about something because
then my kids learn that behavior so
those things change and then also the
way I travel like I flew in today and
I'm flying back tonight immediately
because I want to be around my kids and
it's it's something subconscious it's
not a conscious thing my body requires
like some it craves being around my kids
and so like I'll I'll go
um New Orleans Lafayette Corpus Christi
or sorry Houston Corpus Christi San
Antonio San Angelo to Dallas in a
three-week period And I bring my wife
and kids with me everywhere I go if I'm
gone more than let's say 48 hours I
bring my wife and kids with me because I
you never want I wouldn't ever want to
spend a day without you did you think
that was going to be the case before
having kids so I come from a family of
12 kids okay so my mom and dad had 12
kids I'm number three so family was
really really important my parents grew
when we were raised my parents would
wake me up at 4 30 in the morning would
read the Bible together so like being
around my family was a lot and so I grew
up I was like oh man I'm not going to
have that it's like too much it felt
suffocating like we'd go on vacations
and my Dad we'd go to McDonald's and my
dad wouldn't let us order he's like give
me 12 breakfast burritos and and that's
all you got so when I got older I go I'm
gonna have a family and I'm gonna let my
kids do this this and this and I'm gonna
do it and then you start having kids and
you realize dang my dad was actually
pretty smart like he was pretty
efficient he was this I thought that I
knew better and then when you get older
you go I didn't know anything so you
guys you're planning having kids at some
point one point one point yeah you're I
mean you're really young so
um it is the most Joy I receive in my
life comes from my children and it's
cliche so you understand it but um I
also start realizing that I have to be
more intelligent with my time in
protecting my space I also learned
having kids that public school how bad
public school is and so I'm doing like
you know Heather Torres from think media
and like Sean Cannell and all them so I
talked to Heather about that I think
we're going to start homeschooling our
kids and pulling them out of like
Traditional School I want a private
school so private school is kind of the
same thing that the problem with private
school and this is where you know
talking I sat down with dinner with
Elena and Grant probably 30 days ago and
Elena was talking about the problem with
private school is you're still dropping
your kids off and your kids are now
dead set on a schedule and when you're
traveling and you like right now you
guys are starting to travel you guys are
going out and doing podcasts and you
guys are going to go beyond Wolf of Wall
Street and Ryan serhan and all these
people you're traveling all over if you
have kids and those kids are in school
and it's Monday through Friday now you
have to wait for them to be on vacation
for you to go do your business stuff and
so you start learning private school
doesn't satisfy that homeschool does and
so homeschool allows you to be an
Enterprise owner and be a family man as
well do you worry though that they're
not being exposed to different people
cultures to be honest this sounds really
bad I hope they're not exposed to what I
was exposed to I was exposed to people
that grew up playing video games I was
exposed to people that were doing drugs
but you turned out great but my brother
killed himself I had a brother hung
himself because my brother was exposed
to that and I was not susceptible to
that type of stuff I never wanted I
never drank I've never smoked but my
brother hung himself what was the
difference between you and your brother
I think the difference between me and my
brother sorry my brother his name is
Corbin I named my daughter after him
um the difference was that my brother
wanted to be the cool kid and he would
try and impress the kids that were doing
the stupid things and
um he got sucked into it and you know
there's people that are susceptible to
like alcoholism and there's other people
could drink every single day of their
life and then turn it off I never drank
what happened to me is actually the
reason why I never drink is I in sixth
grade one of my buddies Tyler korth
had a brother that came down in the
basement completely obliterated I'm in
sixth grade so I don't know really
what's going on but he's stenched like
just alcohol stench and he's getting
aggressive getting aggressive he starts
punching things punching holes in the
walls and then Tyler goes oh don't worry
don't don't mind him he's just drunk
this happens all the time
and so something implanted in my brain
like that's what happens when you drink
and whenever I was around people
drinking I was like I'm good like my
wife drinks I don't and it was something
weird that was implanted in me but my
brother like you the second he touched
the stuff he just got sucked in see do
you think maybe he was a little bit more
predispositioned to that than you for
sure probably and do you feel like that
is maybe just the the just the I don't
want to say the luck at the drop yeah I
think there's luck of the draws the same
thing with people have like Hashimoto's
and people have autoimmune disease
people have like obesity issues that no
matter how well they eat or how they
work out their body is just a specific
type I think that I got the luck of the
draw that that was never something that
ever entered into my life but the thing
is just like biological I think
phenomenon or just statistics well think
about this so I have a older brother
named chance and hopefully he doesn't
ever watch this but
my brother chance actually was the one
that introduced a lot of these things to
my brother Corbin and um so chance was
18 or no I'm sorry chance was 16 at the
time and he would get Corbin who was
like 9 10 to sneak out of the house and
chance would go hang out with his
friends and drink and my little younger
brother Corbin was like oh cool I get to
hang out with like my bigger brother and
all his friends well guess what my
brother chance is the head of payroll at
Vivint like he made it out he's like the
dude is smart he's intelligent he's got
beautiful family he just one day goes
I'm done I'm done doing whatever he
turned it off but my brother Corbin
could never kick it and my parents took
him to uh boys camp like they took him
to rehab centers I took him to
everything you could possibly imagine
and
um I went on so I'm Mormon and I went on
a mission to Korea so I get home from my
mission from Korea and I'm like where's
my brother Corbin where's he at where's
he at and where's he at like I couldn't
I was searching for for him for you know
a couple of months and then I found him
in like a drug den and I pulled him out
got him a job and three four months
later he found himself back into a drug
Den it just it just it gets I think once
you get into that world the people I'm
not an addict so I don't know but people
that say once an addict always an addict
I think is just the claws of what he was
into just couldn't get removed from him
horrible it's interesting because I have
a brother too obviously this is very
much different from your example but he
and I obviously we grew up with the
exact same parents in the exact same
house with the exact same like finances
the exact same everything right yeah but
we are we're fairly similar in certain
ways that we would be because we're
brothers but we're also very different
in a lot of other ways and I wonder if
we went under the exact same like
parenting right like what would have
made us different and I always kind of
like toy in the back of my mind at the
fact that like could we have been
parented a little bit different I know
my parents were a little bit more strict
on me than they were on him
um usually it's the other way around
right
like by the time my parents got to Child
Number 12.
it was like we don't care what time you
come home like I you know we've dealt
with this oh I had a strict curfew I got
grounded for 10 months until what you do
Mom and Dad are my mom and dad are gonna
be watching this uh you gotta be like
Iggy don't watch this she probably heard
him what did you do for 10 months bro so
I just had I was a bad I wasn't a bad
student but like in Middle School like I
was a pretty like mischievous kid and
typically the kids that are like yeah
mischievous like mischievous kids that
like end up like you that are like
really awesome they're the ones that
really school's really hard on you I
school was fairly hard on me like at a
younger age but then like as I grow
older I kind of realized okay it's not
too bad but it was funny because while I
was growing up a lot of people thought
that like okay this kid is gonna be kind
of like the degenerate you know what I
mean what's funny is like you were
probably talking to everybody making
friends with everybody making jokes the
whole time but like when you become an
adult those are actually superpowers
yeah and nobody teaches you that in
school like nobody says hey Jack just so
you know you're gonna end up just fine
bro I was I was generally very good
socializing and making friends but
that's all life is kid right and um I
just basically had a parent-teacher
conference that went very very poorly
what happened uh I it was Mrs
Schneider's class Mrs Schneider and uh
she didn't know what she was doing it's
not her fault it's not her fault I
remember uh I was going into the class
with my mom and my we got the parent
teacher conference which is never a good
sign and she basically just said uh your
son and I quote is an extreme
distraction in class which wow basically
my mom's a teacher she's a public school
teacher so she knows like she does not
want to have to deal with that and uh
she understands where Miss Schneider was
coming from she's a very empathetic
person which is I think is beautiful
yeah and she grounded me and for 10.
um talking to everybody a lot of stuff
man so I sat in a normal seat it was a
no it wasn't like that man it was said
in a normal row and I would just I don't
know man I was just always sleeping in
class or I was like throwing things or I
was like with my friends it was never
like throwing things at someone but it
was like playing games with my friends
and talking and laughing and like you
know what I mean chasing each other and
whatnot and she created her uh her own
desk for me it was right at the front of
the class so she had her Podium right
here you could barely squeeze between my
desk and the podium behind me was the
normal row of classes you should when
you buy real estate
you should have an LLC name that's
called Extreme distraction LLC extreme
distraction that's a good idea oh that's
so good yeah but it actually didn't even
end up working me being right in front
of a Podium did your mom actually uphold
the 10 months no yeah so I was grounded
for 10 months but initially and why not
why not nine months and not why not 11
months exactly 10 months let me explain
some things I know it sounds kind of
weird but she didn't initially ground me
with the idea of me have being grounded
for 10 months it was just like yo you
know you're grounded and until we fix
some things until you better yourself
then you can become ungrounded so she
took away my iPod touch she took away uh
my PlayStation controller that I like
just got and also my birthday I remember
was in a couple of weeks and she goes
and I remember we're walking away from
the parent-teacher conference she's like
there goes your birthday
oh yeah yeah and I was like you don't
feel in that moment I was I was upset
but I got it I'm like yeah you know what
I mean like I was annoying kid in class
like I just I definitely didn't help out
with the environment I was just having
fun though and then yeah I was just
grounded and uh I remember it was
actually kind of a blessing because we
were actually robbed that year and the
people broke into the house they stole a
bunch of stuff they didn't steal my iPod
Touch wow it was hidden
so I actually ended up getting my iPod
Touch back and my PlayStation remote the
classic discussion always had the remote
still always looking for the Silver
Lining oh my gosh but I ended up just
kind of correcting some things I became
better I remember like a few months in I
got caught because I I took one of their
old phones to iPhone I was like texting
my girlfriend at the time or whatever
like late at night and she saw it as it
fell out of my pocket or something she's
like you're not supposed to have this
exactly so yeah it wasn't I
got bad and I definitely think I learned
a lot of lessons
to be like who needs an iPod Touch when
you're
how old was I 13 14. it was probably
just a good thing for me not to have
that anyways probably well it turned out
great does Mr Schneider know that you're
on one of the coolest podcasts of all
time uh I don't think she knows that
reach out send her this link bro podcast
dude she didn't do anything wrong she
was explaining what was happening to my
mother so you know Miss Schneider you
know if you ever end up seeing this
thank you for what you did one of one of
Jack's school mates needs to send this
to Ms Schneider please she's a lovely
woman she really is like I have nothing
bad to say about her so
I think it's fine all right all right
okay we're doing it we're doing we're
doing a deal together extreme
distraction LLC cool cool down on thank
you really appreciate it yeah incredible
you guys are my heroes we appreciate you
guys thank you thank you for making the
trip and uh make sure to get your free
stuff down below in the description Down
Below in the description check them out
his YouTube channel will probably be
there too and until next time
cool thanks friend
I would be interested in doing a deal by
the way let's do it